well the new season of The Real
Housewives of New York City is being
called their best ever and one of the
most compelling storylines as Bethenny
Frankel's serious health scares who was
having severe pain severe bleeding and
she had absolutely no idea why lauren
zima is the first to sit down with
Bethenny at her home now the doctors
have finally figured out what was
causing a medical crisis something felt
off I just felt like I wasn't balanced I
had really bad cramps really bad pain
and was kind of experiencing bleeding
again and I went to the doctor and they
said that I had cysts and fibroids
Bethany reveals to ET exactly what's
behind her recent health scare after
becoming anemic and losing 10% of her
blood she underwent surgery to remove
several fibroids first he said that my
uterus grew 50% of fibroids are growing
so fast and it's like having a baby in
there and he's not an alarmist no it's
freaking me out he was like this is a
lot of blood he's like you're bleeding a
lot and he said you have to have a
living will and where will your daughter
be at that time and you'll be in the
hospital for three days like what I had
never even heard of this I mean he said
a lot of people have fibroids but they
don't grow it at this pace what was the
single scariest moment of it for you the
surgery gave me a lot of anxiety and it
never would have if I weren't a mother
it just really was different you don't
like to hear like do you have a living
will you start to think about all these
crazy things how much do you think she
understood of what was going on she knew
something was sort of wrong that she
said is that gonna stop your bleeding so
she understood the mother of
six-year-old Brynn has always been open
about women's health issues talking
about her own miscarriage on her talk
show in 2012 it's not really that mean
of my experience it's kind of just about
being able to talk about it and women
knowing that it's so common and it's not
their fault right I had a miscarriage
which I now think is because of the
fibroids which were growing that was a
really bad time and I think it's the
same thing with the fibroids it's such
it's it's so common and people don't
talk about people will talk about money
people will talk on TV about their sex
life they'll talk about
infidelity everything people don't talk
about female issues are you okay I don't
know I was getting dark warning how did
you get through that some of the girls
in the show were so surprisingly
supportive Carole and Ramona and Dorinda
were very very kind
what are you still dealing with today
just making sure that I've healed is no
I have to go back for my next checkup to
make sure that everything you sort of
back together it's nothing I can really
see so I don't really know and people
say that I look better I've lost weight
so that's maybe not the best people
still commenting on that but I did so I
understand why they're saying that are
you sick of those comments no it's no
I'm used to it don't hate the player
hate the game a part of it you know